bonjour je suis un label chénard
doctorant en physique au centre des
hautes énergies de l'université mcgill
je travaille pour l'expérience atlas qui
est basé au cern à genève en suisse
les détecteurs qu'on utilise ça marche
un petit peu comme un oignon en fait
atlas c'est c'est comme un gros oignon
avec différentes couches chaque couche
chaque peluche correspond à une partie
qui va être capable de détecter un
certain type de particules que ce soit
des millions d'écart ou des électrons et
ses cantons collisions de protons sait
qu'ils vont interagir entre eux se
désintégrer produire des particules des
nouvelles particules qu'on peut ensuite
nous détectée on peut faire le lien
entre ce qu'on observe dans notre
détecteur et puis la physique qui se
passe au niveau de l'interaction de
protons la façon dont les particules
sont produits dans quelle direction et
quels types de particules il s'agit ça
nous donne de l'information sur qu'elle
a été initialement les interactions qui
sont produits à l'intérieur du proton
des deux protons cotisons 30 ils se sont
collisionner alors atlas c'est une
collaboration énorme n'est plus que 3000
le chercheur c'est un aspect que j'aime
bien parce que justement on est exposé à
différents chercheurs avec différents
bacs bruns ça me donne l'occasion de
voyager pour des conférences ou pour
travailler avec eux c'est un des aspects
sympathiques de ce projet